[음악]
여기 한국의 살아 있는 역사를 느낄
수 있는 지역이 있습니다 조선 왕조
500년과 대한민국의 오늘의
이르기까지 한국의 중심으로 나라를
이끌어 온 이곳은
종로입구 손원익 있니다 한옥 한국의
전통적인 주거 형태를 뜻하는
단어인데요 나무와 기화로 이루어져
한국만의 멋을 가지고 있는이 집은
2024년이 지금도 생생하게 살아
있습니다 제가 위치한 노스텔지어 바로
그런 곳입니다 그럼 저와 함께 한국의
멋을 찾아서 가보시죠
[음악]
안개 핀 오솔길 따라 마주한 폭포
시매 속 잠들어 있던 진주알처럼 늘
귀한 것들은 숨겨져 있고 우리는
숨겨진 것을 진귀하다 믿어왔습니다
찾아내는 즐거움이 있는 테마인 히든
제는 야외 자쿠지 정원 그리고
신비로운 음악 동굴이 있는 동화 속에
나올 법한 한옥입니다 쉽게 찾을 수
없기에 그래서 더 가치가 있는
히든재능 가치를 알아보고 즐길 수
있는 여러분에게 온전한 추억을
선사합니다
[음악]
h
북촌 한옥 마을에 위치한 노스텔지어
여러 규제로 인해 건물을 높게 짓지
못하는 한옥 마을에 장점을 살린
최고급 한옥 호텔입니다 특히 한옥
특유의 먹과 기품을 체험하기 위해
외국인 관광객분들이 많이 찾고 있는
곳이기도 한데요 최근들어 외국인
관광객이 더 많아지면서 자연스럽게
부동산 가격이 계속 오르고 있고 그에
따라 노스텔 지어는 미리 부동산에
직접 매입해서 운영을 하고
[음악]
있습니다 12세기부터 청색은 아름답고
우아하며 귀족적이고 신성한 색으로
여겨져 왔습니다 블루젠 오래전
청와대를 위해 구워진 기화와 동일한
기화를 올린 이란 한옥입니다
의미 깊이부터 남다른 블루 제는
과거부터 이어진 시간의 흐름 동서양의
조화를 물신 느낄 수 있는 공간입니다
대청에서 시원하게 내다보이는 남산의
풍경은 블루 젤을 한층 더 돋보이게
만들어 줍니다 도심 속 고기한 푸른
공간에서 따뜻한 물에 몸을 담그고
청색으로 물들어 있는 하늘을
내다보세요
Oh
[음악]
Ah
노스텔지어 도심 속 한국다운 멋을
깊이감 있게 보여주는 휴식 공간입니다
서울 한가운데서 가장 한국다운 거주
공간을 경험하고이 공간을 통해 만나게
되는 아름다움과 설렘을 마주해 보세요
지금까지 공인중개사 손원익이었습니다
[음악]
k